Wonderful.
Amy Vetter, thank you
for being on my show.
How are you?
Great.
Well, thanks for having me.
Really, really great to have you.
I'm very excited for this.
I think that it's going to be fascinating
to hear about your journey
from being an accountant
to discovering yoga.
And now, impacting a lot of people's lives
through your presentations, your books.
You've won multiple awards,
multiple TEDx speaker.
So I'm very very excited
to mainly get to know you better
and learn a little bit about
how you came to where you came to,
and what drove you to those areas.
So, maybe you can take me
all the way back to your accounting days.
And who's Amy Vetter,
and what are you all about?
So, I would say,
all the way back in my accounting days,
I didn't know who Amy Vetter was.
So, I had my grandfather was a CPA.
And from a very young age,
I was saying I was going to be a CPA
because I had known
my grandfather was a CPA.
For everybody who's listening, a CPA is?
A certified public accountant.
Okay. Which means it's for individuals.
You are helping individuals
file their taxes and about their money?
It can be for businesses.
So, a certified public accountant
can do audit.
Where you're auditing companies.
Where you are doing tax returns.
It can be for the individuals as well.
So, like you just said,
at 12 years old,
how would you know what a CPA meant?
So, I basically was doing it
because I was being told about it
and that was my path and my journey.
So, I was very focused on that.
At the same time, when I was younger
through high school,
I painted, I played violin and viola.
I was very artistic.
But once business school
and accounting school
and your early career comes up,
I have to let those things go
because the total focus
was being successful.
And the career that I had chosen.
And that's one of the reasons I say,
like starting out in your career,
I don't know
that you really know who you are.
You think you know who you are.
You think you know who you want to be
until you hit these moments in your career
of you achieve certain milestones
that you wanted to achieve.
And then you're like, wait,
am I happy,
are these the things
that I really wanted.
Did I even question what I wanted,
explore what I wanted.
So, when was that moment for you?
When I became a partner in a CPA firm.
So, that was a moment
I've been working toward.
I was 32.
And when I became partner,
that was a moment of like, wow,
I'm not as happy as I thought I would be.
And I really started doing
a lot of assessment.
I had started yoga at that time,
mainly because,
after I had my second child, I got sick.
So, I wasn't allowed to do
many of the types of workouts
I was used to doing.
So, I was only allowed to do yoga.
And as a type A personality,
that wasn't an answer I really wanted,
but I started really enjoying it.
But also it was very painful for me.
Like I go to a yoga class and cry
and not know
where that was even coming from.
Wow.
But then I'd keep coming back.
And I think there's a lot of fear
around practices like that
because you're alone with your mind.
And then it starts taking you places
and you have to explore it.
And you become a researcher of yourself.
And that really became
the beginning of my journey.
I also started seeing a therapist
at that time of my life,
which I think is really important.
We often talk about business coaches
and things that are professional.
But not necessarily the personal coaches,
therapists, things that we need as well.
From an emotional perspective,
that's an outside.
For a long time I've been saying that,
people go to the gym
three or four times a week
to work on their body.
But they're not even willing
to spend an hour to go talk to a person,
to work on them,
on their inner muscles, right?
So, I completely resonate
with what you're saying.
But going back to this idea
of being a research on your own journey.
So, you're starting this out
when you're having these doubts
as you're entering a partnership
within a large CPA firm.
Now, I'm trying to continue
to bring this back
to young entrepreneurs and engineers,
especially in the environment that I'm in,
whether it's at university
or in the workforce.
In Palo Alto,
things are moving very very fast, right?
Things can get very very hectic
17, 18 hour days.
The progressions seem to be
with no limit in the sky.
As long as you're willing to work
very hard for them.
So, how is it possible for somebody,
I mean, so first of all,
should we be more introspective
do you think, earlier on,
before we had that partnership
where we then start to question things?
Or is it okay to work very very hard
to that and then discover
whether it fits us or not?
Wow, there's a lot in that.
And there's something you said
that I want to stop,
so, I stop and pause on is,
I've worked in the software industry
in Palo Alto, Silicon Valley,
that whole area for many many years.
And when you say success comes fast
and people are working really hard,
success crashes fast, too.
And so, if you are not taking time
to really get to know who you are
and your whole identity,
that success in quotes,
you're going to crash harder
if you don't know yourself at those times.
The other thing that's hard
about those companies
and also being an entrepreneur
and so forth,
and especially if you have a board
and you're taking investors,
is you're replaceable.
And so, you really have to have
an understanding of what makes you happy
besides the work.
And how you can define that for yourself.
And that's really what business balance
and bliss, what my own analogy is about.
The goal being bliss,
and bliss, as I define it,
is the maintenance of happiness.
And a lot of times
we look for outside reasons to be happy.
So, if we use your example,
it's getting the next funding
or the new growth customers
that you want,
or different milestones
you have at the software,
but that comes from the outside in.
Rather than trying to understand
what creates joy internally in your body
and how do you create that yourself
each day.
So, when things are bad,
how do you come back to that feeling
in your body.
So, it sounds like the analogy would be
that these outside,
these external forces,
are like drugs that are feeding off
of your need to use them to be happy.
But as long as you don't have
internal happiness,
you have to have those drugs
because you're not happy yourself.
Whereas in the idea of this bliss,
of maintaining happiness,
it's about how do you generate happiness
through your own inner life
with the things that you do have.
And you don't need to rely
on external sources, right?
Yeah. You identify
what creates happiness yourself,
not relying on other people,
other things,
where you can cultivate that.
And yoga doesn't have to be the thing.
Meditation doesn't have to be the thing.
You can try it.
If it works for you, great.
It can be running.
It can be knitting.
It could be taking pictures,
it could be art, listening to music,
reading, whatever that is.
But, or even going back to thinking
about the things
that when you were little,
like when I talked about playing violin
and viola and painting,
how do you bring some of those things
back in your life,
even if you don't have time to do it.
When you go to a concert,
when you go to an art gallery
and look at other people's paintings
and maybe take an art class.
It's things like that to get your mind
and when you release your mind like that,
you actually are better at work
because you start coming up with ideas
just by having that time away.
Right. Right.
So, then talk to me a little bit
about your experience with yoga.
And what did yoga do to you
that helped you achieve that sort of,
or be on your journey
to achieve bliss?
Well, and I think, like anything,
you have to be ready
for something like that in your life.
And maybe it happens accidentally
like it did for me.
But then, I kept walking toward it
rather than getting scared off of it,
where it was initially about exercising.
And then it started becoming so much more
that I was able to apply it to my life.
And it was really
getting through those hard moments of,
number one, I was never a dancer.
I was never anyone
that can move their body.
Like you went into a yoga class
and you're like,
wow, look at the stuff they're doing.
And I had to let that go off.
I am okay if I'm not perfect at this.
This is not what, it's my career.
It's a little hard
for a type A personality to do.
Totally.
And part of the problem as an adult,
whatever you choose,
whether it's yoga or something else,
is we expect to be perfect at it
at the moment we walk in,
versus we know even in our own careers,
it took us a long time to be good
at what we're doing
and to develop that expertise.
So, we have to have patience
with ourselves to learn that new skill
and not be hard on ourselves.
And that's a really hard thing to do.
But when we learn to do it
outside of work,
it's something we can bring
into work as well,
that not only helps us,
but helps us as a leader
with the people around us, too.
Right. And talk to me a little bit
about the books that you've written
about these subjects,
and about these different experiences.
Yeah. So, I really came up
with business balance and bliss
just to make it a simplified way to think
about anything that you want
to put in your life.
Because they're buckets, right?
The business side is
all the stressors we have, anxiety,
fear, deadlines, procrastination.
You name what your issue is.
Everybody's got something, right?
And we're facing it every day.
Could be other people we work with
that we have trouble with at work,
whatever it may be.
And it's important that we offset it.
So, it's business plus balance
equals bliss.
And the balance side of this
is mindfulness and collaboration tools.
So, it's our human toolbox.
The things that we can do ourselves
to offset those stressors.
So, whether that means
better time management with our calendar,
taking breaks during the day
to walk or breathe or listen to music
or whatever we have to do.
Or learning how to listen better to others
and not speak to over the people
that we're working with.
All of the things
that we can put in place ourselves
without blaming the outside world
in order to create bliss.
That maintenance of happiness internally
by the things that we can control,
not expecting other people
to make that shift for us.
So, why is the business
is such a big part of it?
So, I get the balance and the bliss parts.
But why do you think business
is an important part of this formula?
Because I think that many people,
if you speak to them,
they're going to blame their job,
their family members, the coworkers.
This is why I don't feel good.
I've got this really bad boss.
Or, I'm working like crazy hours
and I'm so tired and I'm so stressed out.
And that all these things that we say
are the stressors in our life,
that's the bucket.
But we actually have the opportunity
to control some of these things
if we choose to
and not let the outside world control us.
And that's really the empowering thing
is once we start practicing,
they are little things,
but once we start practicing them
on a day to day basis,
they start becoming natural.
And that's breaking a habit, right?
Like if even just saying every single day
to your coworkers and friends
how stressed you are,
how much you don't like your boss
or whatever,
what if you just stop saying that.
How would that change
how you felt each day.
And maybe change the energy
that you were putting out
with the people around you
and to your boss.
That might make a little shift.
You never know.
So, it's these things
that we can identify ourselves
that can shift those stressors.
So, I'd also have to touch
a little bit about impacts.
And I understand,
especially in these worlds,
a lot of the coaching
that happens one on one
has a lot of direct impact
on the person that is learning.
You might be helping a CEO
or an executive go through their life
and think through with them
how they can help make these adjustments
to be a little bit happier.
But now, I'm wondering on a larger scale.
Because you've given countless talks
and keynotes and TEDx presentations,
and so many different people
were impacted by them.
Is there a way for you to know the impact
that you're having on them?
Or how do you even resonate
with a large crowd
as you're talking about these big ideas
where every person is trying to adjust
into their own life?
Well, I think the way,
my style is telling some of my own stories
so that people
can internalize that themselves.
So, when I am authentic and vulnerable
and telling things that aren't necessarily
great stories about myself
or when I had hard times,
other people can as well.
And I think part of the world problem,
is we only see the outside of people.
And so, people can make assumptions
all day long about me or you and and say,
"Oh, their life's seem perfect."
Or, things just come easy for them.
And when they learn the stories
behind the person,
then you become more real.
And it's no different
when you go back into the workplace.
And instead of looking at everyone
from the outside,
how could you get to know someone
from a more human standpoint.
And from a speaking perspective,
I can't know every single person
that I make an impact with.
But what I do know is
the people that come and talk to me
or message me after
or that end up wanting to the,
I have an online learning program
that helps them actually
implement this in their lives.
The people that want
to take those actions.
But I've seen many people
post the things that they went back
and started playing guitar again,
or painting again or doing these things
because they got inspired to go do it.
And that is what keeps my fire going
because I'm like,
Okay, then what I'm doing is worth it.
That it's helping others.
But it has to come from,
I think a very authentic place.
It's not that the goal is the career,
and I think that's the big shift
after your thirties.
It's about purpose.
And if you're younger
and you don't have purpose
behind what you're doing,
it can become very empty.
And so the earlier you can really identify
your purpose and passion,
and if the work you're doing
is aligning with that
or if you feel out of alignment,
then what can you do to fill in that gap.
So, what is one tangible thing
that I can take with me
as I go into the office tomorrow
and try to implement
some of this more well-rounded,
balanced thinking
and internal introspection?
What can and should I do
throughout my day or throughout my week
to make it a little bit easier for me?
Well, and many aren't going
into offices right now
and we're not in meetings
and so forth,
so, I think what's really important
is how you man your calendar, first off.
So, I'm really a big believer
that a meeting
does not have to be 30 minutes.
It can be 25
or instead of an hour, 50 minutes.
So, you can build in breaks
in between meetings to decide
what you want to do on those breaks.
And I call it at least taking two minutes
to either meditate, to get up,
walk around, do some stretches,
listen to music,
whatever you need to do.
So that you don't leave one meeting
and then let that snowball
into the next meeting.
And then by the end of the day,
you're so stressed out or frustrated,
you don't even know if the frustration
is from that person
or if it's just the snowballing
from the day.
Totally. And I can imagine that now,
during covid, that everything is so quick.
And right after this meeting,
I go and I answer all these messages
with the one minute I have
before joining the next Zoom call.
So, it's a little bit crazy.
Which part of your job
do you enjoy most?
Is it the writing, the speaking,
the meeting, the online learning,
what is it?
I love what I do.
I don't have, I mean,
speaking, I would say obviously,
is the number one thing I love to do
because I love the light bulbs going on.
And you can see the impact immediately
where some of the others
is the longer term thing.
But I really love interacting with people.
So, most of my job is that.
I love it. Okay, Amy, first of all,
I want to thank you for being so generous
with your time and for being on the show.
I truly appreciate it.
I know how busy you are.
And the last question that I want to ask,
the most important one and fun one
are three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
And why those three specific words.
I know you gave me till the end.
So, I'm a mother, first off.
I'm very proud of the two boys I have
that are teenagers.
Confidence, that I think
that it has helped me a great deal,
to be able to take on risks
and opportunities
and go through failures as well
when needed
and go through the hard times.
And I would say loyal to the people
that have been good to me back.
Like that I have
very long term relationships
and even knew people like,
I think anyone that is
in that circle of trust,
we have very strong, deep relationships.
I love it.
Amy, thank you very very much.
I truly appreciate it.
And continue to make a positive impact
on people.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Wonderful.